hello welcome to war so my name is Miko
I and I'm gonna be a tour guide to the
next couple of minutes and I will take
you for my tour in the lovely polish
capital war zone
we used to share the
this is the worst old towel everything
here was actually constructed just right
after the Second World War so you just
need to come here and see the symbol of
Warsaw which is the mermaid
so let me introduce now to you the
Palace of Culture it's the most iconic
and symbolic building of war so and
actually it's that much hated and that
much love because it's a gift from
Joseph Stalin and in some point for many
people it's a symbol of the Soviet
domination in worse
this place is quite unique because some
people are even saying that this tower
is here is the best place in Warsaw
because it's the only one place in
Warsaw from which you can't see the
palace
Warsaw is a really vibrant city right
now and you can really find plenty of
places where you have young people
sitting outside on the street and the
culture of spending time in the weekends
and during the week is just changing
year after year and some people are
saying and actually Warsaw it's a it's a
new Berlin also like a cool and sexy
city to be in
we are in the very special part of
Warsaw right now and this is Moran of
district this was actually a heart of
ghetto during the Second World War
here you can see the monument which is
showing the heroes from the Jewish
uprising here in the ghetto and on that
side you can see one of the newest
examples of the modern architecture
which is a Museum of the history of
Polish Jews the fact that I love about
Warsaw is that actually year after year
we are still having more bikes than cars
so maybe one day we're gonna have more
bikes in the center than the cars
it was quite a long day but you know
it's almost impossible to show you the
whole city just in a couple of minutes
but I hope I did attract you and you
will come towards so very soon actually
I need to eat something right now
you